I became prime minister at a time when
there was no money left and I bring this
with me everywhere the note that the
Treasury Minister left and it's it there
it is dear chief secretary I'm afraid
there is no money that is the situation
I inherited so we've had to make
difficult decisions over these last five
years and I accept not every one of the
decision has been easy for people but
the truth is five years on the deficit
is halved
two million people are backing work the
economy is growing faster than any major
economy in the Western world and I think
what this election is about is do we
build on that foundation and build a
really strong country where you can get
a job you can keep more of your own
money to spend as you choose
you get that apprenticeship we can build
houses for people to buy and own or do
we go right back to the start with Ed
Miliband potentially propped up by the
SNP who want even more borrowing even
more spending even more debt all the
things that landed us in that mess in
the first place I never want us to go
back there again